on s'excuse on se retrouve sur pizzas
des ouïes version 2 alors on avait livré
la première pizza c'était plutôt bizarre
comme comme livraison warning ce jeu est
là on gamers de 15 ans on va tomber à
londres se retrouve la prochaine fois
pour une autre vidéo sur lesquels a tant
besoin
ok c'est parti ou alors qu'est-ce qui
change des graphismes sont un peu mieux
un bon c'est toujours sympa lumière qui
ne les ont toujours aussi glauque mais
je crois qu'on peut toujours pas courir
non les touches ont le même bon quel
drame va cette fois touché la maison
un scénario pas possible une falaise
acté la maison j'ai pas de pizza
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît c'est
qui cette fois je vous traduis en
français pizza delivery of you vient
rentre je serai là dans une minute entre
qui s'ouvrent toutes seules
le jeu alors better place de pizzas and
the toy boys ok j'ai mis sur la table
donc c'est le même sérieux que l'autre
même scénario que le pardon mais
seulement star hockey etc et à des
tableaux de fantômes dans sa maison qui
n'a pas l'électricité dans sa maison au
piaggio ça que j'aime chez du mannequin
youtube the j'ai mon téléphone je peux
voir depuis avec c'est grâce à sa
lumière
ok d'accord c'est bon crash ou dancers
et iam inclus aux phobiques ça doit être
peur du noir
sûrement est-ce que je peux monter les
marches qui se passe chip east wing à
d'accord ok donc il a peur du noir donc
là il évite une maladie oh oh je vais me
mettre dans une position foetale premier
tableau des fantômes
ce tableau des fantômes et appuiera sur
du monde par marc homme m'a un jour ce
serait là quand l'électricité reviendra
je dois partir maintenant
[ __ ] de merde qu'est ce que c'était
est-ce que je peux monter sans aucun
effet plutôt nul
bon très bien aujourd'hui nous allons
prendre les bonbons pendant que ok ce
que je peux apprendre cette bougie oui
je sens une présence tard
s'il vous plaît cat bonds non là
peut-être la plus glauque du monde à la
pièce la plus vite du monde ça ne change
jamais cette maison est toujours aussi
affreuse c'est alors qu'est ce que nous
avons un cinquième un léopard un billet
forme actuelle je me cache avec ma pizza
aux normes car elle n'est pas là
pourquoi je me suis pris un d'accord
donc ici quand tu vas sous le plafond
tu ne vois plus rien c'est un alors
est-ce qu'on peut pas prendre le
téléphone non bombes ont fait une sieste
aller alors qu'est ce qu'on a ici des
allumettes got money for the pizza c'est
bon tu cherches le gros bâtard il ya des
morts était dans la maison jean michael
je m'attache au revoir aux bobards
décembre 1 mais tout va bien dans cette
maison tout est parfait ce que b s'il
vous plaît maybe elle est peut-être en
bas n'est pas un étage en bas comme on
va regarder où aller il ya quoi y'a rien
à une table comme all your eyes et à le
vibreur de break qu'elle est fan tu as
ce bruit stressant au plus haut point
dernière vidéo vous êtes tous fait avoir
au téléphone alors yes je t'ai couach
on a un pokémon qui appellent au secours
aux chips ou est tu petit pokémon like
us open
ok je n'ai pas tout à fait compris mais
bon bombardé son époux fait la fête la
fête tout de trouver la plus grande
bouche du monde
ok bon quotidien qu'est ce qu'on fait
my fox je ne peux pas continuer comme ça
est ce qu'un zombie va arriver par cette
fenêtre est ce qu'on va se faire violer
dans la cheminée
annie to stop loving m'annoncer que
don't walk on the wild eyes wide shut
binghamton
j'attends hockey le coeur doit se calmer
j'attends non
quoi on a perdu dans pizza delivery non
quelqu'un qui mange un corps bizarre bon
c'est tout à fait normal
alors pour la zone est à changer d'avis
ok nous revoilà au moment où notre homme
fait une petite crise de deux clics de
quelque chose et ne doit plus bouger
miles kane taxes des éléments alors
est-ce qu'on va devoir arrêter ça
arrange pas il nous dit de ne pas bouger
mais c'est la fin ok donc avec qui bouge
pas espère voir noir c'est la fin mai
d'un gourdin mais juste un pécule sur
l'oeil
je suis dans la maison en train de
dormir dans mon lit
est ce que c'est un cauchemar et
maintenant découvrez regarder tout
pourquoi ça m'est arrivé
pourquoi moi pourquoi moi libre de
pizzas parmi les 600 mille livres aux
pizzas hockey et c'est bon alors ne
bouge a disparu tout est tout à fait
normal faut que j'aille dans la match
box absolument pas où c'est peut-être
des fèves et très mal aux yeux bah ça
match box
quel genre de personne transport tu me
bouger dans son sac à main dites le moi
alors moi en cas de panne je n'ai pas
une lampe torche
j'ai une bougie oh je sais ce que tu
cherches que je vais te rendrais liberté
suis moi quoi elle est adepte du
football
cette femme vol yahoo
je suis sûr que j'accepte s'il vous
plaît ok maintenant à merci non je
voulais te remercier
ah ça fait peur non vous êtes sérieux
oh [ __ ] mais non mais non mais non je
me regarde en boîte de mouchoirs
voilà c'est bon c'est pas mieux ou tard
je me cache je me suis caché dans
l'armoire comme un gros steak c'est bon
nous y sommes enfin quoi perdre à
observer avec quoi ok très bien
follow the peas non mais c'est pas que
ça va recommencer on va encore retrouvé
deux groupes pantin il animé par terre à
la cua cette fois ses pizzas
non je ne sais pas c'est la fin des
géants suit le morceau de pizza
et maintenant suivis des morceaux de
pizza pendant 30 minutes
oud ou la ouate
c'est l'armé des jaloux qui nous ont
attaqué je crois qu'on s'est dit non non
non non non non non non pas une
troisième papa une troisième map m
maintenant que je tous ensemble le fola
plus nous tous les tensions et des
vidéos